sometimes I sit back and just kind of
wish we could have a normal president it
was noticed that Donald Trump took no
notes during his bizarre meeting with
Kim jong-un in Singapore and when he was
asked about it his explanation was he
doesn't need notes because he has one of
the great memories of all time if you
want to talk about delusions of grandeur
and narcissism it is this video clip of
Donald Trump take a look is a very
heartfelt conversation
you know I don't have to verify doesn't
have one of the great memories of all
time
remember that Donald Trump also said
last week that he didn't really have to
do much preparation for the summit and I
guess that ended up being true since I
predicted two months ago that North
Korea would agree to the same stuff they
always agree to and that they haven't
actually done but what I want to focus
on is Trump's claim that he has one of
the great memories of all time
Trump's memory is terrible right Trump
supposedly couldn't remember anything
about his entire affair and pay off with
stormy Daniels he couldn't remember
having repaid his lawyer Michael Cohen a
hundred and thirty thousand dollars in
hush money and just yesterday he
literally couldn't remember the name of
the new Italian Prime Minister that he
met just days ago I mean he couldn't
remember the guys name take a look I
have a very good relationship with Prime
Minister Bobby I have great relationship
with the new men who I like a lot as you
know from Italy he just won and you know
we had very good and frankly a really
good with Merkel
really good pretty much with all one of
the great memories of our time doesn't
remember the name of that guy the world
leader from Italy that he met three days
ago
here's Trump forgetting that he had
mentioned John Cornyn 15 seconds earlier
and mentions him again and says oh I
didn't mention the guy this is from
February a big win we had Mitch
Senate Majority Whip John Cornyn John
thank you great job
House Majority Whip Steve Scalise again
Steve thank you sir mentions Cornyn
House Majority Leader Kevin McCarthy
Kevin chair John Thune and House
Conference chair cathy McMorris Rogers
did they forget your name John I don't
know what's going on here john cornyn
everybody knows they didn't put his name
up but that's okay it's the first time
that's ever happened that will a gent
that'll never happen again in 15 seconds
forgetting that he just mentioned John
Cornyn and then here's a personal
favorite of mine Donald Trump who I
guess forgot Rudy Giuliani's face looks
like wonders where Rudy Giuliani is when
he's sitting right in front of them with
that I want to introduce Rudy Giuliani
and who's going to be working with Jared
Kushner
and with Tom Bassett we're also here and
Rudy is very much of an expert on
cybersecurity it's been a very important
thing to him and to what he does and
maybe I'll ask Rudy to say a few words
well thank you thank you very very much
mr. president first of all
congratulations on what is in fact a
historic come on guys if Trump's memory
is so incredible why did Rudy Giuliani
actually say it's not a good idea for
him to speak to robert muller because
memory is malleable and the truth is
relative if trump's memory is really so
great sit him down with robert muller
and let's get this thing over with what
once and for all
Trump's like the kid who badgered others
for studying for a test in school or for
putting on their seat belt it's almost
like a point of pride that he doesn't
take notes
100% intelligent lucid brilliant people
take notes James Comey for example comes
to mind whose notes are of particular
interest and this is just another one of
these attempts to appeal to the lowest
common denominator of intelligence it's
sort of like a faux superhuman thing
going on and it actually does influence
some of trumps followers who just eat
this stuff up hey man did you see Trump
you didn't even need to take notes for
that summit it is absolute and utter
nonsense